-Thank you for being here buddy.
-Thanks for having me.
-It is always great to see you.
You look great.
-Thank you.
-Last time we talked,
you were telling me that you
were into these ice baths.
You remember this?
I have a photo of you.
Here's you in your friend's
trash can.
-Oh, yeah, the trash bin.
-With ice.
-And it was like, all about
breathing and freezing yourself.
-It was good. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
It's good for the body,
a good reset.
Good for training.
-Yes, gets the blood moving.
-I actually, I was doing it
the other day
with a buddy of mine,
and when you're doing it
in a bin like that,
you're putting 120 pounds
of ice in, a bunch of water,
but it's not that cold.
It's probably like 40 degrees.
-Mm-hmm.
-My buddy has one that's
32 degrees,
which is 0 degrees Celsius,
for anybody who's watching
over there.
That's, like,
freezing temperature.
So I got into it, and I hadn't
done it in, like, 6 months.
I'm sitting there, and after,
like, two minutes, suddenly --
by the way, screaming, like,
I was yelling.
I was like, "Ahh!"
I was like, "I can't move.
Why's my body locking up?"
It felt like the blood
was freezing in my body.
Obviously, it wasn't.
-You froze yourself?
-I'm a bit of a drama queen,
clearly, but...
-So you're still continuing
to do this?
-Yeah, I love it.
I think it's great.
[ Laughter ]
-Sounds fun. Sounds amazing.
Give me a second to get
back into it.
Once you get back into it,
it's --
-I want to talk about
"Black Adam."
I'm so excited. Everyone's so
excited for this movie.
And you were telling me
something funny backstage.
'Cause you have a great sense of
humor and you're very fun.
Every time you've come on,
we've done bits, joked around.
-Water gun fight.
-Yeah. We've done everything.
Can you tell everyone what you
were telling me?
There was a big action scene.
-Yes.
-You have to run 40 yards.
-Yes, yes.
-With all these parked cars,
and then you have to run back.
-The other way.
-You're wearing your
superhero costume?
-Full, in garb, right?
Everything's covered.
It's 100 degrees outside.
It's Atlanta, you know?
It's humid.
-Those suits get hot, right?
-Well, yeah, yeah.
There's no, like -- the skin
is totally covered,
which looks badass.
-Yeah, of course.
-But when you're doing
wind sprints --
-Look at this.
This is that I'm talking about.
-Yeah.
-That's what I'm --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Alright, so you're running
through 100 degrees.
-We did, you know, we did not
that many takes.
We did six takes,
and they're like,
"Should we do one more?
I'm like, "Yeah, you know.
Why not? I'm game. This is --"
You only get to do this
so many times, right?
So I'm like,
"Yeah, let's do it again."
So I'm running, and I go,
"This time...
let's make it funny, right?"
Let me try to make it funny.
So I'm running off the curb.
There's a parked car.
I pretend to hit my knee
on the parked car
as I'm running.
And I spin around like,
"Ahh," like that hurt.
My arm goes up,
and then dislocates.
[ Laughter ]
-Dude, that's --
-Fully out of socket.
I'm like, "It'll go back in.
Hold on. Hold on.
I'm gonna move it back in."
It did not go back in.
-So now it's not a joke.
-No, so, well now, yeah.
Exactly.
Now I'm like, "Okay, hold on.
Stop, stop, stop running."
And keep in mind, the suit
is tight, right?
It's like a glove fit.
-Yeah.
-And so they're like,
"What's wrong?"
I'm like, "My arm's
out of its socket."
So they go down and they're
trying to get it.
It's not going back in,
so they have to
cut the suit open.
They open it up,
they take it down.
I'm sitting there like, "I can't
believe this is so funny."
And 13 tries later,
with a foot in my armpit
and a guy pushing from behind,
they just --
whoom.
It goes back in finally, right?
[ Crowd groans ]
And I'm like, "Woo, yeah!"
Throw my arms in the air.
I'm like, "We're back in!"
When my arm goes in the air,
it dislocates again.
[ Laughter ]
-That's the best story.
Oh, my gosh.
All because you wanted to
do some funny bit.
[ Laughter ]
Why not?
-So they were like,
"Let's try it again."
I was like, "Fire in the hole!"
-Yeah, exactly.
-They got it on the third time.
It went back in
and that was that.
So yeah, it was an action movie
for sure.
-Yes, it is.
Well, let's talk
about this movie.
This is "Black Adam,"
who, of course, is played
by Dwayne Johnson.
-Man.
-And we love him. Oh, my God.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-You're a tall guy.
You're a big dude.
I would say, next to...
-I'm like, uh...
You know, compared to him.
-Yeah, no. Yeah.
-He's pretty big, but...
-Yeah.
-I'll tell you this, though.
I might be smaller than him.
The moment I saw him,
I had one thought in my head.
"I could take him."
-Wow!
-Yeah.
-Really?
-I'm looking at him,
he's looking at me.
I'm going,
"Oh, I could [bleep] you up."
-Oh, my God! No, no, no.
That is not true.
How far away were you
when you said that?
[ Laughter ]
-He might have been, like,
500 feet away, but...
-Yeah, yeah, yeah.
That's smart. That's smart.
He's one of the greatest guys
to hang out with.
-The best.
-Did you end up picking up
any of his mannerisms?
Can you do the eyebrow raise?
-Oh, the little -- the thing?
I don't know. Should we try it?
-Yeah.
[ Clears throat ]
Ooh, hey!
That's actually not bad!
[ Applause ]
That's great!
-I do it like --
-Also Pierce Brosnan.
-Wait, can you do it?
-I think I --
-Can you do the eyebrow thing?
[ Laughter ]
-Can't really do it.
I can't really do it.
-I don't know which eyebrow
is worse.
I can't.
I'm blinking on that one.
Pierce Brosnan,
also in the movie.
-Pierce Brosnan, yeah, no.
It's an amazing cast.
-Do you get intimidated,
'cause, I mean,
he is James Bond.
-Oh, yeah.
Hard to not be
intimidated by him.
He's a titan in the industry.
-He's a cool customer?
-Just cool.
That's the thing about
Dwayne and Pierce, though,
is that their reputations
precede them,
that they're these
magnanimous people.
And then you meet them,
and they're so disarming.
They're so kind,
and they're just so supportive.
-Yeah.
-And they're fun to work with.
I remember one time,
Piece, we were getting ready.
Everyone's in character.
We're on the Hawk Cruiser,
which is insane, right?
You're introduced to
all these new characters,
and we're sitting there,
and they're, "Alright.
Should we shoot the rehearsal?"
And he just leans over to me
and he goes,
[ Clears throat ]
[ As Pierce Brosnan ]
"They're all rehearsals."
-Yeah!
-I was like...
-That's the secret of acting.
The secret of acting is,
they're all rehearsals.
-I was like,
"You're so right, dude."
-Yeah.
How do we set up what's
happening in "Black Adam"?
-Mm, uh, okay.
You got this, the original god
chosen by the gods,
Black Adam,
who's been asleep for
5,000 years, gets woken up
and starts to wreak havoc, and
so the Justice Society, who --
this is the first time
for Black Adam
in the cinematic universe as
well as the Justice Society,
which predates even the Justice
League, 1940s, I believe.
They get -- We get recruited.
So it's Hawkman,
it's Dr. Fate.
They're on the Justice Society.
And then they recruit
Atom Smasher and Cyclone
to come and take care of
Black Adam,
see what's going on.
-Yeah.
And could you ever see maybe
a spin-off for Atom Smasher?
-I would [bleep] love to.
[ Laughter ]
You guys, it's up to you!
-Yeah, it's up to the fans!
-I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Noah Centineo
in "Black Adam."
Take a look at this.
♪♪
-That is insane.
[ Monitor warbling ]
-The nanobots did
most of the work.
-No, no, no. I'm not gonna
let you downplay it.
I literally just witnessed
a miracle.
-[ Scoffs ]
-What?
Did I say something stupid?
-No.
It's just, you can transform
your molecular structure,
grow 100 times your own size.
You're an impossibility,
and the world still amazes you.
I don't know, it's...
It's cool.
-Thank you.
But it's not as cool
as nanobots.
-Yeah! Noah Centineo!
"Black Adam" is in theaters
and IMAX October 21st!
We'll be right back with
more "Tonight Show," everybody.
Stick around! Come on back.